[Aplausos]
[Música]
y si os dijera que hay un país que tiene
tres presidentes del gobierno a la vez
con los problemas que de uno solo pues
imaginar tres a la vez pues bien ese
país existe y se llama bosnia
herzegovina y si nosotros también lo
hemos pensado con tres presidentes
podríamos hacer un canal como visual
político dedicado en exclusiva a este
país aparte de tener una historia
trágica como pocos es una de las mayores
anomalías políticas del mundo porque si
mi querida comunidad de visual política
aparte de tener tres presidentes y es el
único país de europa junto con turquía
de mayoría musulmana pero no sólo eso si
sabéis fijado el nombre del país es
compuesto es decir se llama bosnia
herzegovina y os preguntaréis pero
porque ese nombre pues bien son dos
regiones históricas juntas al fuego bina
es el extremo sur del país que supone
aproximadamente una quinta parte de su
territorio el resto del país se
corresponde con la bosnia histórica pero
si hay algo realmente anómalo en este
país son sus fronteras atentos a este
mapa
[Música]
literalmente podríamos decir que las
fronteras de bosnia están pensadas para
que no tenga salida al mar hecho como
vamos a ver más adelante podríamos decir
que sus vecinos conspiran para que
bosnia nunca pueda tener costa o al
menos nunca pueda tener una costa
importante y la poquita que tienen está
a punto de quedar prácticamente
inutilizada
pero nada de estos va a sorprender
especialmente si habéis visto los
últimos vídeos de visual política en los
que hablamos de como bosnia fue la mayor
víctima de la guerra de los balcanes en
los años 90 es tarea de este país es una
auténtica tragedia así que la pregunta
que hoy nos hacemos es cómo es posible
que bosnia haya llegado a tener tres
presidentes del gobierno porque no
tienen costa porque la poca costa que
les queda puede quedar prácticamente
inutilizada a partir de ahora hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes
sabéis cómo podéis apoyar a visual
político de forma activa pues exacto
entrando en nuestra comunidad de patria
no sólo estaréis contribuyendo a que
visual político siga adelante además
tendréis acceso al merchandising como
esta camiseta que llevo puesta que no
está a la venta la única forma de
conseguirla es formando parte de nuestra
comunidad en patrio pero no sólo eso
también tenemos contenido exclusivo y
una newsletter semanal las claves de la
semana donde tratamos temas que no nos
da tiempo a cubrir en forma de vídeos
así que ya sabéis os espero a todo el
mundo en la comunidad de visual
politiken patriot y ahora sí vamos a ver
un poco de historia
21 días en dayton
para explicar ese mapa tan extraño que
tiene en bosnia herzegovina hay que
remontarse bastante en el tiempo
concretamente hasta finales del siglo 17
por aquel entonces prácticamente todo el
territorio de los balcanes estaba
controlado por el imperio otomano todo
dubrovnik esa ciudad tan bonita de la
actual croacia que muchos conoceréis por
el turismo era una república
independiente era la república de ragusa
pero por esta zona también se movía la
república de venecia que quería ir mucho
más allá de sus canales y controlar el
mar adriático para eso los venecianos no
paraban de conquistar territorios de la
costa dálmata que por cierto también
pertenece actualmente a croacia de hecho
habían llegado ya hasta las fronteras de
la república de ragusa y diréis que
pensaron en esta república hace
trescientos años pues lo siguiente
ni más ni menos que poner tierra de por
medio literalmente y regalar el imperio
otomano esa franja costera de 20
kilómetros en la que se encuentra la
ciudad de neón así es como quedaron
protegidos de una invasión terrestre por
parte de los venecianos y desde luego el
trato no les salió nada mal a los de la
repubblica de ragusa pues evitó la
amenaza veneciana y aguantaron su
independencia hasta los tiempos de
napoleón y esta fue la fórmula que
permitió que ahora bosnia herzegovina
tenga su única salida al mar
[Música]
ahora bien para explicar el resto de
cosas que hacen de bosnia herzegovina un
país tan especial no hay que irse tan
lejos apenas tenemos que situarnos en la
década de los años 90 del siglo 20 hace
30 años la antigua yugoslavia se
desmoronaba y las repúblicas que le
integraban empezaron a proclamar su
independencia en el año 1992 fue el
turno de bosnia y herzegovina y así es
como estalló el peor conflicto étnico de
toda la guerra de yugoslavia
bosnia y herzegovina peleaban tres
bandos entre sí los bosniacos de
religión musulmana luchaban por
sobrevivir los otros azuzados por serbia
y croacia querían repartirse bosnia eran
los dos no croatas católicos y los
serbobosnios cristian ortodoxos estos
últimos estaban ganando la guerra los
serbobosnios dominaban más de la mitad
del país y se independizaron proclamando
la republika srpska la unión de los
bosniacos y los bosnio croatas contra
los serbobosnios cambió el signo de la
guerra
lo cierto es que todos se comportaron
como unos salvajes en este conflicto
cada bando intentó purgar de otras
etnias las áreas bajo su control pero lo
cierto es que los serbobosnios se
llevaron la palma durante más de dos
años tuvieron bajo asedio a la ciudad de
sarajevo con continuos bombardeos contra
la población civil y con los
francotiradores haciendo de las suyas la
masacre de srebrenica fue el mayor
genocidio de toda la guerra de bosnia
allí los serbobosnios mataron a más de
8000 bosniacos musulmanes
en este panorama occidente se decidió
intervenir y la otan lanzó una campaña
aérea que duró tres semanas la llamada
'operación fuerza deliberada en este
momento es cuando los serbobosnios
comprendieron que no les quedaba otra
que negociar la guerra de bosnia había
durado ya tres años y medio el país
estaba devastado la mitad de su
población había sido limpiada
étnicamente o simplemente había huido
pensad que murieron más de 100.000
personas y para cerrar un acuerdo de paz
fue necesario encerrar durante 21 días a
los líderes de bosnia croacia y serbia
en una base aérea estadounidense que
estaba en dayton en ohio y grace pero
porque en ohio porque no en europa pues
ya os lo podéis imaginar en la guerra de
los balcanes europa y los gobiernos
europeos poco tuvieron que decir así que
fue estados unidos quien finalmente
apadrinó la paz en dayton las
discusiones fueron al detalle pero de
verdad rozando al absurdo o sea
imaginaos a tres jefes de estado que se
van a eeuu a pelearse día tras día por
pueblecitos es decir por si está la
aldea queda en tal o cual territorio y
al final qué pensáis que pasó con poner
de gobi na pues algo tan curioso como el
mismo nombre del país veréis si un día
en él os preguntan cuáles son las dos
entidades en las que este país se divide
administrativamente
no no son bosnia por un lado y
herzegovina por el otro para nada
las dos entidades que forman bosnia y
herzegovina son la republika srpska que
está integrada por las zonas en las que
los serbobosnios son mayoritarios y la
federación de bosnia y herzegovina en la
que conviven los bosniacos que son la
mitad de la población total de todo el
país y los bosnio-croatas de esta
federación a su vez se divide en 10
cantones
[Música]
y de estos 10 cantones 5 son de mayoría
bosniaca es decir musulmana 3 de mayor y
acróbata es decir católica y en los
otros dos cantones pues qué queréis que
os diga yo francamente creo que clinton
estaba ya aburrido y dijo venga mira
dejadlo y así aunque sea con las sepias
mezcladas porque si no sois capaces de
quedaros otros 21 días aquí en dayton y
ahora vamos a tener que mandar la
factura del hotel que esto no es gratis
ya lo sé esto puede parecer un chiste
pero no os creéis que se aleja mucho de
la realidad las fronteras de bosnia
están definidas pueblo a pueblo y eso
explica que tengo una forma tan rara en
este mapa podéis ver las dos entidades
la república ser pesca por un lado y la
federación bosnia acá por el otro
y en este otro mapa se ven los 10
cantones
como podéis ver no hay una división
clara esto no es norte sur y este oeste
sino que toda bosnia es su auténtico
desbarajuste en el que la constitución
ha consagrado las diferencias étnicas y
esto afecta a todo por ejemplo las
infraestructuras porque claro las
conexiones entre puntos de diferentes
etnias son muy pero que muy complicadas
solo 139 kilómetros entre banca luca la
capital de la republica ser pesca y
sarajevo que es la capital del país sin
embargo la carretera más directa tiene
190 kilómetros y se tarda nada menos que
3 horas en hacer el trayecto pero ojo
porque también afecta a las escuelas
donde las etnias están segregadas y por
supuesto también afecta a las
instituciones políticas por eso la
presidencia del país recae en tres
presidentes uno representando a cada una
de las etnias que se van turnando cada
18 meses para ejercer como titulares de
la jefatura de estado en definitiva que
está claro que los bosnios fueron los
que acabaron pagando todo el odio que
generó la desintegración de la antigua
yugoslavia
la cuestión es pero de verdad todo este
caos funciona pues ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tres etnias dos entidades y una secesión
alguna vez habéis pensado que vuestro
país tiene demasiados políticos pues
atentos al caso de bosnia cuatro
millones de personas vivían en bosnia
herzegovina antes de la guerra
actualmente a duras penas se superan los
tres millones de habitantes hay quien
cree que con una población tan escasa
este país le iría mejor con un alcalde
sin embargo bosnia tiene tres
presidentes un primer ministro otros
doce primeros ministros regionales y
catorce parlamentos con unos 700
parlamentarios y por supuesto no penséis
que hablamos de un tipo de
descentralización a la suiza para nada
sino en un modelo político burocrático
mucho más parecido a lo que es habitual
en el mediterráneo' todo ello en uno de
los países más pobres de europa donde
los servicios públicos dejan bastante
que desear y en el que los políticos
básicamente discuten sobre las mismas
cosas que ya les llevaron a enfrentarse
en una guerra
como os podéis imaginar ante este
panorama los jóvenes emigran en cuanto
tienen una oportunidad y la población
envejece el sistema instaurado en dayton
solamente está siendo útil para los
políticos nacionalistas de bosnia que
por supuesto anteponen el beneficio de
su comunidad de su etnia sobre el bien
común del país
[Música]
en este ambiente tan envenenado es donde
putin está intentando desestabilizar los
balcanes y como os contábamos en otro
vídeo que hemos hecho hace poco visual
polític desde hace meses los
serbobosnios se sienten respaldados por
rusia para plantear un desafío
secesionista y esto no son futuribles de
hecho en diciembre del año pasado el
parlamento de la república srpska votó a
favor de empezar su desconexión respecto
a las fuerzas armadas el poder judicial
y el sistema fiscal de bosnia fue toda
una declaración de intenciones ya que
ello provocó que tanto eeuu como el
reino unido- sancionarán a milorad dodik
el representante serbio de la
presidencia que sugirió que los
serbobosnios pedirían ayuda a sus amigos
rusos en el caso de que la otan
interviniera en post lo cierto es que
esta no es la primera vez que dedica
amenaza con la asociación de la
república srpska pero como podéis
entender que todos salte por los aires
resulta muchísimo más creíble ahora
mismo sobre todo después de la invasión
de ucrania sin embargo por el momento
tendrán que esperar líder serbobosnio
dodik dice que la guerra en ucrania ha
[ __ ] el plan de secesión por ahora
ha quedado postergado durante seis meses
pero este plan supone que la república
estar pesca empiece a elaborar nuevas
leyes para que los serbobosnios tengan
sus propios sus propios jueces y por
supuesto su propio ejército esto último
resulta especialmente delicado sobre
todo si tenemos en cuenta lo que pasó 30
años antes en la guerra pero esperad un
momento porque el de los serbobosnios no
es el único frente interno que amenaza
el futuro de bosnia herzegovina como un
país unido los bosnio-croatas también
están reivindicando su identidad
los bosnio-croatas llevan décadas
quejándose de que cualquier habitante de
la federación de bosnia y herzegovina
puede participar en las elecciones para
elegir al representante croata de la
presidencia del país esto significa que
ser bosnio-croata no es requisito
esencial para participar en esta
votación una situación que está siendo
utilizada por los nacionalistas
bosnio-croatas que aseguran que el
representante de su etnia la presidencia
es aupada al poder por los bosniacos
musulmanes
esta protesta se intensifica en momentos
como el actual cuando el representante
bosnio-croata de la presidencia presentó
un perfil algo más moderado que los
nacionalistas más radicales y por eso
los partidos nacionalistas
bosnio-croatas están uniendo fuerzas
ahora para pedir cambios en la ley
electoral están dispuestos a llegar
hasta las últimas consecuencias y
amenazan incluso con un boicot para las
elecciones generales que por cierto este
país celebrará el próximo mes de octubre
del año 2022 los croatas aseveran que
pueden impulsar su propia región a no
ser que cambie la ley electoral así que
tal y como estamos viendo bosnia
herzegovina atraviesa actualmente un
momento crítico en el que sus políticos
están apostando por acentuar las
diferencias étnicas y por supuesto tanto
serbia como croacia avivan estas
diferencias en otras palabras que la
estabilidad de bosnia herzegovina sigue
en entredicho pero esperado un momento
porque esto no es todo recordáis esa
pequeña línea de costa de la que
hablábamos al principio del vídeo pues
atentos
[Música]
un puente que aleja de europa
bosnia herzegovina solicitó entrar en la
unión europea hace seis años como os
podéis imaginar en bruselas nunca se les
ha tomado en serio y ni siquiera les han
concedido el estatus de candidato
oficial simplemente han indicado 14
reformas prioritarias que tendrían que
hacer en este país estas reformas
afectan a su sistema judicial la
garantía de derechos fundamentales y
libertades o la lucha contra la
corrupción pero desde entonces sarajevo
solamente ha cumplido con uno de los 14
puntos indicados por bruselas algo que
evidentemente aleja a bosnia de la unión
europea así lo explicaba a mediados de
junio oliver bargel y el comisario
europeo para la ampliación
en
este ejercicio ven a steve el fortín
fire it is dead of bin lade out in
europe ya no
y
las reuniones con las instituciones
europeas son continuas pero las
tensiones internas hacen muy difícil que
pues ni herzegovina desarrollen las
reformas exigidas por bruselas así que
todo ese entusiasmo de la unión europea
se ha transformado en decepción
bosnia acaba de ver cómo ha sido
adelantada por ucrania y por moldavia
que han recibido de repente el estatus
de candidatos oficiales a entrar en la
unión europea una condición que sarajevo
lleva años intentando conseguir y que
por razones obvias nunca le han dado un
golpe que además viene acompañado de
otra noticia que aunque no lo parezca
tiene un significado mucho mayor del que
podría parecer a simple vista sin pasar
por bosnia el enorme puente que
transformará los viajes por los balcanes
las obras de cimentación del llamado
puente de peyé sat comenzaron en el año
2007 pero como os podéis imaginar todo
el proyecto se ralentizó en cuanto
comenzó la gran recesión del año 2008
desde luego aquella no era la mejor
época para construir puentes el proyecto
se quedó sin dinero y se cancela en el
año 2012 sin embargo croacia no renunció
nunca a buscar la mejor fórmula para
sortear el corredor de neu he echado un
vistazo a este mapa
actualmente la carretera que atraviesa
el corredor de neón recorre 9 kilómetros
a través de bosnia herzegovina y diréis
dónde está el problema pues lo cierto es
que hasta ahora no pasaba nada malo los
vehículos transitaban por esta carretera
y no se requería el pasaporte para
transitar por el corredor sino se salían
de la misma y se dirigían de nuevo a
croacia ahora bien todo esto va a
cambiar a partir del año 2024 por qué
pues porque entonces croacia llegará a
conseguir algo que llevaba años deseando
entrar en el espacio schengen
un requisito para ser miembro del
espacio schengen es que los viajeros y
sus vehículos sean controlados tanto a
su entrada como a su salida de los
territorio schengen en este sentido
conocían descartó instalar un puesto de
control en el corredor de neu ya que
empeoraría los atascos de tráfico que ya
se producen durante los meses de verano
y precisamente por este motivo es por lo
que probaría decidió retomar el proyecto
de construir el puente de peljesac
además la pandemia ya ha supuesto para
los croatas tener que plegarse a las
restricciones impuestas por bosnia para
transitar por el corredor de neu esto es
un motivo más para impulsar el famoso
puente de peljesac que ya está cerca de
culminarse de la mano de dos socios de
pesos puente félix sachs de croacia
financiado por la unión europea
construido por fina lo cierto es que el
puente de peli sat se inaugurará el
próximo 26 de julio y será una realidad
gracias a que bruselas ha puesto el 85
por ciento de los 430 millones de euros
que costará esta infraestructura
una vez que este puente de 2.4
kilómetros este operativo ya no será
necesario atravesar el corredor de neón
para los turistas que quieran dirigirse
a dubrovnik toda una metáfora de cómo la
unión europea está dando largas a bosnia
herzegovina de cara a su posible
adhesión acabando con sus esperanzas
mientras este país contempla cómo se
está reviviendo con los brazos abiertos
a otros aspirantes y si esto es un duro
golpe especialmente para todos los que
creen que entrar en la unión europea
sería la mejor garantía para que bosnia
herzegovina continuará siendo un país
sin embargo la pregunta que os dejamos
para vosotros es de verdad debería la
unióneuropea apostar por incorporar a
bosnia herzegovina igual que está
haciendo con ucrania creéis que los
acuerdos de dayton son un lastre o son
necesarios para la convivencia hasta qué
punto entrar a la unión europea serviría
para algo en un país que como ya podéis
ver tiene unas instituciones están
absolutamente locas podéis dejar me
gusta respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que aquí en
visual polític sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribir a
este canal y darle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones les ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]